c'est pas pourquoi on en est arrivé là
quoi je suis là depuis la première
émission du 1er avril 2010 je suis
encore joueur à marquer d'une pierre
noire phone mango son t-shirt arrivant à
un amas de pierres et un dimanche je
reçois un texto diana qui est dit à mon
frérot demain tu fais tmp sinon on va
parler des battues société au début
moins vite et j'étais content aussi sur
ce lien
oui tu veux pas faire l'émission je dis
bah si elle accepte pas bon signe moi
ici
débarqués ont conduit verte les bip
c'est bientôt noël comme on m'avait pas
prévenu je pensais que ça allait être la
fête les cadeaux mais c'était pas que ça
j'étais seule ville humilié habits on
finit bien au minimum à 10 m en compte
at on vraiment très chaud
prénom ton cul vraiment déguise en armes
j'ai pas compris que bon ça c'est la
diète je suis tombé dans la piscine
on m'a demandé pourquoi je m'énerve
c'est pourquoi je criais mais c'est
parce qu'il fallait que ça sorte quoi il
fallait que tout ce mal être sorte quoi
en dalida moi j'étais pas venu pour six
jeunes hurlaient ma douleur s'est passé
dès lors autant que ses douleurs annoncé
richard fortin merci j'avais envie de
dire que ce que j'ai fait aucune bête de
leurs effets oui j'ai passé des
centaines de chroniqueurs et après on
voit ça a basculé dans un tourbillon je
me suis entraîné et je me retrouve en
geneviève de fontenay la scène j'ai
basculé de 4 ans qui s'habille d'art
carats sera frérot mon bébé mais chéri
j'avais plus du tout le même langage et
les clients de matin en une raison le
voyage avait changé d'idée gagez pas
changé pour lever un petit f
je serai toujours le real sera toujours
dix mois dont quatre mois blanc comme
ton cv du encore mais c'est long mais
non je suis content évidemment je suis
content habib leur zèle novembre travaux
au début je croyais pas du tout
franchement je croyais pas le vouloir a
misé un euro sur le dollar
bonne anniversaire pg npa parce que tu
es très près c'est vraiment une belle
famille et c'est vraiment joli souvent
justement c'est une récré est ce un
bonheur absolu
voilà c'est vrai des jeunes avant et un
après une passe de cyril ordinaire c'est
une famille je pense ma petite voisine
isabelle c'est comme ma soeur ma maman
et ma grand-mère les la norme ils m'ont
beaucoup de dérision et c'est la folie
du sport on bosse de quoi rigoler de
nous mêmes mon ami rendez vous le 4
avril le 4 avril rendez vous le 4 abri
rendez vous le 4 avril
rendez vous le 4 avril pour les 9 ans ne
touche pas
[Musique]